in some senses some people would say
that you know this is the biggest test
of the banks uh the banks since becoming
independent this rise in inflation the
the rise in interest rates what would
you say to those who say that it's it's
effectively failing that test failing to
see the rise in inflation failing to see
how sticky it's become now it's up at
the top failing to understand the nature
of food price inflation as well
do you think that those failures matter
in your ability to to maintain
credibility
that
the backdrop to this is that the shocks
that have been hitting the UK economy
and of course the global economy
actually as well we must look at it
through that lens as well have been much
larger
so we've set these shocks out and of
course I've referred to a lot of them in
my opening remarks the largest one of
which is the impact of the you know
terrible war in Ukraine on both energy
and food prices no question about that
and it's of course it's the test of this
regime as is how is how we deal with
them and how we return inflation back to
Target
now I think you can look at that through
two lenses therefore one is what is
causing the shocks the second is you
know how are those shocks anticipated
and then how do we deal with them in
terms of returning inflation Target
because that is the objective of the
regime obviously that we have
sustainable inflation over the medium
terms we're sustainably low at Target
inflation
that is what we're doing
um we have to you know we have to adjust
from meeting to meeting as we see news
and I'll pick on one piece of news that
you mentioned I think the the point on
food prices let me just come to that
there is a very big underlying shock in
food prices and you know we showed I
showed the chart which showed the same
thing is going on in Europe
as a whole
now
I think the news that we've had is not
about persistence in the sense of
long-run persistence
it's the question of how
over what time this shock Works its way
through the the system if you like
and how quickly we expect that to
dissipate now what yeah we're hearing
and as I said I hear it around the
country which I've been doing a lot
since we were last here
is an expectation that it will we will
see a reduction in food in food and food
inflation indeed we already seen so some
of that beginning
but it is taking longer and the the
reasons I hear that it's taking longer
are sometimes to do with the impact of
energy prices and food production
sometimes to do with you know hedgings
hedging approaches that have been used
at the commodity price level so that
although as I said commodity prices you
know started to fall last year it's
taking longer to come through now I
think you know I'm happy to sort of in a
sense debate well how much of that is
predictable and how much of that is is
emerging but those are the things we
have to deal with and yes we do revise
our views as we see new evidence I think
that's appropriate